there are no very concrete commitments  yet from the EU and we do know that a  lot of countries that will be at a cop  21 may data criteria they can only agree  on an ambitious cop text if there is  sufficient climate finance McLoughlin  police masala and Clara's man dad and  easy fat and a little fat gain disease  expect a leading the Kurdish I nagar in  the screens oblast on the under and  practice arsenic within day  industrializing countries and I guess  that's almost all of Europe really there  there's beginning I think to be a real  impatience with the global deal la  quadrature du qua Coentrao hello you  passed lady tigers Canseco legally  binding etcetera may e foothill a day  zelim oh yah Medgar raffle opinion  public april AP you ma'am Ellis attitude  crucified discussion politics in yard  set Anika  you